[Música]
estamos en france 24 para hablar de
cultura y con un tema que es obligación
de cada año la ceremonia de los premios
oscar que este domingo celebró su
edición número 94 y para hablar del tema
puede ser la experta de aurel en nuestra
periodista de cultura de france 24
lea gracias por estar con nosotros y
vamos a comenzar hablando de cuál es ese
primer balance de esta noche que tuvo de
todo después de un año de pandemia con
muchísimas restricciones bueno angela
fue una noche llena de sorpresas la
mayor es que kodak señales del corazón
una película de cine independiente y de
plataforma ganó el premio a mejor
película mientras que la favorita el
poder del perro' con sus 12 nominaciones
al final se fue con sólo una estatuilla
aunque no cualquiera ya hablaremos de
esto un poco más tarde pero una de las
imágenes que va a dejar huellas en esta
edición número 94 de la de los premios
es la bofetada que dio will smith al
comediante chris rock en pleno escenario
las ml se desarrollaba con normalidad
con tranquilidad y el momento de
anunciar el ganador del mejor documental
cristo que hizo un chiste malo sobre la
cabeza rapada de la esposa de will smith
jada pinkett smith que parece alopecia
que es la pérdida de su cabello
consecuencia de una enfermedad
autoinmune y eso es lo que provocó la
bofetada y luego los insultos de wish
miss una secuencia irreal todo el mundo
pensó al principio y yo también que era
parte del guión seguida de un giro muy
oli bullense unos minutos después cuando
ulises ganó el premio a mejor actor por
la película reid richard donde
interpreta al padre de las famosas
campeonas de tenis serena y venus
williams will smith muy emocionado en el
escenario pidió disculpas a la que temía
por su gesto y es su primer oscar a
mejor actor claro y en la reivindicación
en aras de tener algo de equilibrio lea
se habló mucho del gesto de crisis
rockets habló mucho de will smith pero
no se habló de la principal afectada que
fue de lleida smith y como esto pues fue
una forma de violencia hacia una persona
que tiene una condición médica
y violencia por todas partes y al final
will smith pidió disculpas reese rock no
dijo nada pero bueno vamos a continuar
hablando ahora del triunfo sorpresivo
digamos de caudas señales del corazón
usted cree que era algo que podía
esperarse pues coda fue un éxito total
el fin del festival de cine
independiente de sundance un festival
muy que pesa mucho en el mundo del cine
pero no era para nada joda la favorita
en esta edición de los óscar es sin
embargo en los últimos días antes de la
ceremonia había rumores de que este
filme podría sorprender con el galardón
y eso es lo que pasó angela tres
nominaciones y tres estatuillas
la primera mejor adaptación de guión a
porque esta historia viene de un libro
francés que luego fue adaptado en una
película la familia y la familia vélez
muy exitosa en francia cuando se estrenó
pero según mi punto de vista equidad y
sólo que raras veces pasa ser mejor que
la original tiene que ver con la calidad
de los actores y actrices y con una
representación
más justa es la historia de una
adolescente oyente que vive con dos
padres y un hermano sordos a diferencia
de la familia billy esta vez los
personajes son interpretados por actores
sordos droid colsur se convirtió en el
primer actor sordo de la historia a
ganar el oscar a mejor actor de reparto
fue un momento muy emocionante de la
ceremonia el tal como el anuncio del
premio a mejor película el galardón más
prestigioso al final de los oscar así
cosas se convirtió en la primera
película de un servicio de streaming en
ganar este premio porque solo se estrenó
en apple títulos es el triunfo de las
plataformas pero también es una linda
victoria para el cine independiente y
además histórico porque su compañera
precisamente de su web pique coequipera
en pantalla marlee matlin e también fue
en su momento mejor actriz también por
sorda y de en 1986 ganó por children of
a lesser gad así que bueno son 12
intérpretes que se van con sus
galardones para la historia
estos son argumentos son más que
suficientes para animar a estas personas
que todavía no han visto kodak a que
vayan y la descubran mientras tanto que
nos puede decir sobre los otros
ganadores de la noche bueno lo que puedo
subrayar también después de estas
sorpresas de la noche es que varias
películas se fueron con los premios que
se habían provisto pronosticado el
primero el ópera cósmico épica dunne de
individuos no sé si lo has visto
angela no por supuesto es así en
espectáculo es un espectáculo total
y esta película que no es seis
estatuillas sobre las diez nominaciones
que tenía es el récord al final de esta
edición número 94 de los oscar bueno son
todas para categorías técnicas mejor
sonido mejor
dirección artística mejor montaje mejor
fotografía mejores efectos visuales y
mejor banda sonora original para hans
zimmer el solamente el segundo oscar en
esta categoría para el muy famoso
compositor alemán después de su premio
por el rey león' en
1994 bueno y es que cada tanto salen
estas sagas
de películas pero pocas veces logran
emocionar tanto como este efecto que ha
causado y que ya estamos esperando la
siguiente entrega además con ese elenco
de actores maravillosos hay de todo pero
bueno la dejo para que continúe más
información de don que tenemos si es que
tú lo interesante también en esta en
esta edición de los óscar es que ganó de
una cierta manera la batalla contra el
poder del perro que tenía bueno diez
nominaciones el poder del perro dos
denominaciones y un bueno no era el gran
favorito y el poder de pero parece haber
sufrido esta maldición que afecta a las
películas con muchas nominaciones pero
que salen de la ceremonia con pocas
estatuillas de oro pero como lo anuncia
al principio de este programa
jane campion la directora neozelandesa
de este western psicológico ganó el
premio a mejor directora es el segundo
premio más prestigioso después de mejor
película y entonces son dos mujeres las
que salen ganando de esta edición con
100 eder la directora estadounidense de
coda era para jane campion la segunda
nominación a mejor directora después de
el piano en
1994 y es la primera vez en la historia
de la ceremonia que una mujer gana este
premio dos años consecutivos el año
pasado era close how con numeral en
también una película con un ritmo un
poco lento pero una fotografía
impresionante y lo hemos dicho desde el
año pasado este año lo volvemos a
repetir qué bueno sería que esto no
fuera una gran sorpresa y una gran
noticia sino que fuera la normalidad no
porque evidentemente directoras buenas
hay y hay muchísimas vamos a seguir
hablando de las victorias de las mujeres
pero ahora con el oscar a mejor actriz
de reparto este es un caso muy especial
sí y arianna de voces sin dudas y va a
ganar están merecido su premio en los
que han visto a la nueva versión del
clásico musical vuestra historia saben
que cuando aparecía en la pantalla
arianna de voces no se puede mirar otra
persona ella roba toda la luz actuada y
la canta hizo una performance ya
increíbles y su discurso fue también un
gran momento porque ella explicó lo
simbólico que fue ganar siendo una
actriz afro latina y queer y la historia
se repite porque la actriz que
interpretaba su papel en la película
original de vuestra historia había
ganado también este buscar en
1962 y última estatuilla que todo el
mundo esperaba la que ganó la japonesa
raid michael herck para mejor película
de idioma extranjero la película del
director ryusuke taguchi es preciosa
tanto por el lado de la imagen como por
la sensibilidad en la interpretación de
los actores es una película que ya había
ganado el premio a mejor guión en el
festival de cannes el año pasado y que
rinde homenaje al arte entonces merece
merece la pena de verlas bien y vamos a
hablar ahora también de estos momentos
de la ceremonia que usted quisiera
destacar ya hablamos de los obligados
ahora que más tuvo esta noche de los
premios bueno no se puede hablar de los
premios oscar sin hablar del premio a
mejor actriz obviamente que ganó este
año 10 y que haya están por su rol de
una popular presentadora evangelista
estadounidense en los ojos de esta mi
feria en esta categoría de mejor actriz
competían actrices de gran talento sobre
todo kristen stewart que jugaba una lady
perfecta and spencer pero hace muchos
años que el mundo del cine esperaba
premiar a jessica ya esta que impresionó
al público en la noche más oscura a la
película sobre la muerte de osama ben
laden a que se estrenó en 2012 y otra
categoría con muy buenas películas este
año la de mejor documental summer of
soul sobre el jardín control festival de
1969 se fue con el galardón en una
inmersión fascinante en este festival
que también llamaron el stock negro pero
otro documental que hubiera merecido
según mi punto de vista este premio es
free una película de animación que sigue
la historia de un hombre afgano huyendo
de su país como refugiado y en los
momentos de música los colombianos
esperaban esperaban esta ceremonia por
la actuación de dos canciones no
solamente unas dos canciones de la
película de animación de disney en canto
dos órbitas que contó sebastián y atrás
en el escenario de los oscar porque
estaba nominada a mejor canción original
pero también no se puede hablar de bruno
al tema súper exitoso de esta película
sobre una familia colombiana con poderes
mágicos encantos ese fue con la
estatuilla de mejor película de
animación lo que refleja al final el
amor del público por esta obra pero son
biblia y ni si su hermano líneas que se
fueron con el premio para mejor canción
original por el tema no time to die que
escribieron para la última película de
james bond un tema que interpretaron
también durante esta esta noche y quería
terminar angela esta especial sobre los
escalando de mi película favorita de
esta edición que también tenía una
nominación para mejor canción original
para down to droide balmori zona y es
vez belfast es la historia de semi
biográfica de su director irlandés
kenneth branagh él la describió además
con su película más personal y cuenta la
infancia de un niño en medio del
conflicto de belfast en irlanda del
norte entre protestantes y católicos y
afortunadamente se fue con estatuilla de
mejor guión original y para dar ganas a
nuestra audiencia de ver está muy muy
linda película nos despedimos con el
tráiler de belfast
con esta estrella
mismo aquí entonces mojan
[Música]
la danesa por una pasión
bien
[Música]